We're moving on to the Fitzgerald stories and I just want to make an
announcement,
um,
about a possible a field trip to New York City,
uh,
movie Emrae.
One of the teaching fellows,
um,
is,
uh,
organizing a trip,
to see the,
uh,
production,
of,
uh,
on the sun also rises,
which is another novel.
I haven't ways by this select in spite of elevated,
uh,
what is,
what is the grip call express elevator service.
Um,
so,
um,
it's very interesting.
They,
last year did,
did the great Gatsby.
Um,
so it's,
uh,
it was right here,
um,
and at Yale Rep.
So it was a very interesting group and it looks like they're going to keep on
doing this extended readings,
but also dramatic readings of the novels.
So if you guys would like to go to see the sun also rises,
just email,
email,
movie.
Um,
and um,
I should,
I'm just gonna get started on the first year I was stories.
Um,
and we might be under the misimpression,
um,
from reading the short stories that may be a Fisher went to Yale.
He didn't,
uh,
he was Princeton class of 1917.
Um,
and this was actually a kind of very interesting that I found from the Princeton
Library.
Um,
that's the kind of receipt that he had at the triangle club and because so many
who's show stories have to deal with clubs,
the Yale Club and so on.
Um,
it's interesting just to have this document showing that he was a member of the
triangle club.
Um,
and this is a letter that he wrote to his classmate also Princeton,
uh,
1917,
last Lowell Fowler who would go on to become a very prominent and a New York
lawyer,
the founder of a very prominent law firm.
This is what he wrote to the follower.
I have written a 15,000 word story about your car.
The rich boy.
It is in a large measure,
the story of your life tuned down here and there and simplified also Manny gabs
had to come out of my imagination is frank unsparing the sympathetic and I think
you are like,
it is astonishing the huge things of that anyone would as the like this story
that is supposedly based on their lives.
Uh,
but in any case,
this is what Arthur sometimes think about their own work.
Um,
so you know,
I think we know just from our edition in,
in the short stories,
um,
that there were a couple of episodes that are like little follower made,
Fitzgerald tech out there,
reinserted it now in brackets.
But obviously there was historical proof that little fall,
it was pretty upset by the story.
Um,
but in any case,
Fisher or really thought that this was a story about a friend of his and that
the friendship was as they,
what propelled him into writing the story.
Um,
so he is also in that story that he lays out his theory about fiction and
especially the way that characters are to be described in fiction.
So he is hysterical.
Begin with an individual and before you know it you find that you have created a
type began with a type and you find that you have created nothing.
They all know types.
No Thoreau's there is a rich boy and this is his and not his brother's story.
All my life I have lived a mom,
his brothers,
but this one has been my friend.
So it was still saying in within the story itself that this is about someone,
um,
who he still calls his friend physicists theory.
Let's see what's Fitzgerald does in practice because we know that quite often
there's a distance between what others profess that they're doing and what they
actually end up doing.
So this is his practice right on the next page.
Let me tell you about a very rich,
they are different from you and me.
They processed and enjoy early and it does something to them,
makes them soft where we are hard and cynical where we are trustful in a way
that unless you were born rich,
it is very difficult to understand.
They think deep in their hearts that they are better than we are because we have
to discover the compensations and refuges of life for ourselves.
Even when they entered deep into our world or sink below us,
they still think that they are better than we are.
So let's say a couple of things here.
First obviously if that Fitzgerald was using a tight social label is,
is turning a rich boy into a social type and generalizing about this entire
social type.
So in many ways he is doing exactly what he says.
Writers should never do crusading with a title.
But I think that we should also say that given the fact that he is using a type
that the rich boy is kind of generic identity,
uh,
the he honors that he recognizes as a reality that even though he is doing that,
um,
his,
the contents that he attributed to that type,
Ashley,
I'm pretty interesting.
Uh,
according to him,
Arish boy or the rich are people who are different from people who are not rich
because of two things,
right?
That they are soft,
where we are hot and that they are cynical.
Where we are trustful those to actually pull in two different directions.
If we were just to take the first one that they are soft,
where we are hard.
That's very,
very understandable that because they didn't have to struggle all that much.
They don't have the kind of Holly Hood that comes to people when they have to
struggle a lot just to get the bare essential oils from life.
Um,
so that would be completely understandable.
But what is interesting is that right after that comes the statement that
completely is on the other side of the spectrum that whereas the rest of us are
trustful,
the ridge actually us cynical.
So how could this be under what circumstances with the rest of us be trustful,
whereas the rich would be cynical.
This is not so self evident.
It is something that Fisher would just throw out.
It's kind of a generalization seemingly,
you know,
just something that he would make a casual point that he would make.
Um,
well actually it's quite puzzling.
So we have to figure out in the course of the story of the rich boy why it is
that even though there's salt,
most of the times they are also moments when they are actually harder than we
are.
They are more cynical than the rest of us.
Um,
so in any case,
so all we can say at this point is that even though yes,
Fitzgerald uses social types in his stories,
um,
that here's a very interesting understanding of those social types.
So we can say that he's really not so much subscribing to the notion of social
types as playing with them,
putting pressure on them,
uh,
looking at all the possible permutations of social types.
So this is,
um,
something that we've already talked about a little bit last week when we talk
about to have and have nots and Hemingway's use of those two types of have and
have not.
So today I want to go back a little bit and give you in many ways the,
so the genealogy to that kind of thinking,
thinking in terms of social types.
And it actually goes back to the mid 19th century.
This is a very,
um,
famous texts,
scientific texts,
what aspires to be a scientific tags,
uh,
by Dusa not and George Clinton,
called types of mankind.
And if you guys are fans of Stephen Stephen G.
Good,
you'll see that there's this tax was actually mentioned by Stephen Jay Gould and
his book mismeasure of Mendez where I got my information from.
So in 1850,
um,
the understanding there's a clear correlation obviously,
between the,
the,
the facial features of a Caucasian person,
very Greek looking person,
classic go profile,
um,
and this kind of very flat,
facial structure,
bone structure,
the phase,
um,
the girl corresponds to the facial features.
And then obviously the implication is that blacks and gorillas actually have the
same skulls.
I'm Asian,
so you can,
we can see where this is heading.
This is the sort of signs,
um,
that is quite common.
Um,
in the mid 19th century of talking about social types in order to suggest a very
close kinship between certain types of humans and certain types of animals,
that's the embroiders behind that kind of taxonomic thinking.
Um,
so this was in the mid 19th century.
and by the 20th century that pretty much has receded into the background.
So let's look at another kind of thinking about types.
Um,
and as we can see from this very sober looking,
um,
no thrills,
no nonsense.
Look of the treaters.
Uh,
this is a very highly respected sociological treaters by Burgess.
Either you verges and Robin as for the park,
um,
introduction to the science of sociology.
And it turns out that social types,
the notion of social types is crucial to the birth of sociology.
So this is what Robert E.
Park says.
I did not see how we could have anything like scientific research unless we had
a system of classification and the frame of reference into wish we could sort
out and describe in general terms the things we were attempting to investigate.
So the system of classification and a frame of reference into which we should
sort out and describe in general terms,
I was plead as a degree of abstraction going on the degree of generalization
going on.
We need to be able to generalize from individual cases and other to create a
system of classification.
So in many ways that's the very foundation of the sinus car sociology.
Um,
and Fitzgerald is very much,
uh,
and Hemingway as well.
They were both very much moving in that kind of,
you know,
um,
very pervasive,
very common intellectual climate.
So,
um,
I wanted to stop here for a brief moment and talk a little about about the
interconnections among the tabs that we've read so far.
Um,
as you guys recognize,
um,
in last week when we were talking about to have and have not been talking about
Harry Morgan,
um,
as a kind of attention,
the character is attention between type,
between label of generic type,
um,
and deviation from type as we mentioned that in fact it's only when he is
mediated through the presence of other people when he's channeled through Marie
or when his contrasted with Rob Gordon,
um,
that he actually becomes somebody who's not the social type.
So that's Hemingway thinking about types.
I also want to go back a little bit further and refresh your memory about the
sound and the fury.
Um,
and the sound of the fury.
We talk a lot about the relation between today and tomorrow are obviously time
is central to the time to sound the fury.
Um,
and we were talking about Benji Quentin's and Jason's tomorrow as one of the
most important things linking the three brothers.
So today what I like to do is to combine those two,
um,
analytic structure is to create a new structure to talk about Fitzgerald's short
stories.
We'll be talking about tight and variation,
but mapped onto the concept of the relation between today and tomorrow.
So if you belong to a certain type,
if you can be labeled by a generic identity while there's the possible future
for you though as the possible tomorrow for you.
So basically a combination of Hemingway and thought there.
Um,
but I also want to introduce new layer,
a new analytic layer into our discussion,
which is the difference between a story that is dramatic and the story that is
not dramatic.
And the four stories,
um,
that we're,
we're reading today represent very interesting permutations on that platform.
So we'll be talking about that too.
And this is just a very quick run through of the argument that I'll try to make
today.
Um,
rich boy is about excessive conformative to type tomorrow.
It's going to be exactly like today.
And so it's not dramatic.
Babylon revisit it is in many ways a kind of rewriting of Richard Roy of rich
boy,
um,
is about someone who conforms to type to a large extent,
but not entirely.
And what happens when that's the case then?
So tomorrow is not quite low today,
but still is not a dramatic story.
And then we move on to two stories.
They're very dramatic.
Um,
diamond as big as your risk,
as we know from the Tido is large scale dramas,
very,
very dramatic.
Um,
and then Bernie is barbs,
her hair,
small scale drama,
but also dramatic.
So,
um,
but less move,
look,
take a closer look at rich boy.
Um,
and even though a Fisher went into Princeton for some reason,
yeah,
is the reference point for him.
So the Yale Club,
um,
is a social marker and it's very interesting that actually Fitzgerald,
makes the point that,
um,
that's a hundred actually was not popular when he was at Yale.
So he Fisher was making a distinction between Yale College in new haven and the
Yale Club in New York City.
And he's really talking about the Yale Club in New York City and not so much
about college.
Um,
so,
uh,
and,
and is devoted to the Yale Club.
He's always there,
but there's also the sense that maybe it's too much of a good thing.
And so there's the possibility that excessive conformity to type his,
the Yale Club type,
that being too much of that will actually lead to some kind of deviation.
So,
but first of all,
this is the diversion to the Yale Club.
Um,
but he never abandoned the Yale Club.
He was a figure there,
a personality and attendancy tendency of his class who are now seven years out
of college to drift away to most solo.
Hans was checked by his presence.
So this is a very unremarkable centers in other ways.
You know,
it's not something that we will know.
This is very matter of fact or three neutrally descriptive.
Um,
he is a pillar of the owl club.
and his presence there,
um,
is an anchor for other people,
so they stick around because of him.
So there's really nothing to say one way or another really about this
description of ensign hunter other than the fact that it's a little odd to seven
years of college that the owl club is still this very center of his universe.
Um,
so it's just beginning to look a little art.
But the description in itself is not especially dramatic or noticeable really.
Um,
but
more towards the middle of the story,
in fact,
um,
after some things have happened,
we know the hints Mrs Chance to marry Holler.
Um,
he misses his challenge to marry Darley.
his lives seems to be,
um,
a catalog now of things that are not done.
Things that he could have done that he chooses not to do or the WHO perversely
allows not to happen,
um,
is beginning to look that way.
Um,
and it is at this moment that the excessive devotion to the Yale club becomes
almost a summary of what kind of person he is.
It was a hot Friday afternoon in May and as he walked from the pier,
he realized there Saturday closing had begun and he was free until Monday
morning go where he asked himself the Yale Club,
of course,
bridge until dinner,
then four or five Raul cocktails in some of these room at a pleasant,
confused evening
is still quite neutral.
Um,
it's not registering any shock,
um,
about this non turn of events.
Basically nothing happens in adolescence live.
Right.
You know,
so all these things that could have happened that would have been a significant
development in his life,
significant turning points,
all those important turning points where rose not taken by Anderson.
Um,
and so he's still going to the Yale Club,
but at this point going to the Yale Club becomes a measure of the poverty of his
life.
Right before it had been attributed to the fact that he's such an important
presence there.
There's a pillar of the Yale Club.
Um,
now he's going there because he doesn't have anything else.
So is a description from being a plus in this life,
something that he has,
you know,
on his resume that he's such an important figure at the Yale Club from being a
plus on his resume,
it becomes,
um,
not exactly a minors but a sign that things are just darling not to go well for
him or that we beginning to take this to see that some things are beginning to
go wrong.
So if the indication,
um,
of,
of alive that is not taking shape as it should.
Um,
and the story really is about the possible shapes of one's life.
F as in Mary,
the hollow,
we're taking them very,
very different shed is the fact that he doesn't allow his life to take that
shed,
that it retains the original shape,
which I guess is good.
In one sense,
it wasn't so bad shape to begin with.
Um,
but the fact remains that this absolutely no change in his life that tomorrow is
going to be exactly like yesterday and like today.
So,
um,
this is the very end of the story.
Um,
and this is on the boat.
and the narrator is,
I'm actually happy that things have,
um,
that this is how things stand for Anderson.
And he told me about the girl in the red town and is the Avengers with her
making them are bizarre and amusing as he had a way of doing.
And I was glad that he was himself again,
or at least the south that I knew and book,
which I felt at home.
I don't think he was ever happy unless someone was in love with him,
responding to him,
my filings to amount that,
helping him to explain himself,
promising him something,
what it was.
I do not.
Perhaps they promise that there will always be women in the world who has spend
the highest freshers rare is ours to notice that superiority be cherished and
his whole life.
So it is in many ways of poetry,
of a social to hype.
Uh,
the way it comes back to that soup,
recognize about social profile.
Um,
someone who,
uh,
because he has such a large and guarantee and very,
very secure in companies,
very,
very successful in his firm.
Um,
and he's the pillar of is the head of his family.
because so many things a given in his life where there's also a given,
it's the understanding that there will always be a supply of women who have
gravitate towards him and be bowled over by him.
People are still bowled over by him if they just see him for the first time.
Um,
and is that capacity,
that knowledge,
that certainty that there will always be women who will be bowled over by him
that makes him what he is.
Um,
so Fitzgerald,
his definition of the rich boy extends far beyond the amount of money that adds
and hunter has.
Um,
even though that is not an unimportant consideration,
uh,
but it really is in many ways the stalling point for whole kind of psychological
profile about what it means when someone takes a lot of things for granted.
Um,
and the ways in which taking so many things for granted can actually be a kind
of psychological liability.
Um,
it's actually not good for us according to a Fitzgerald,
um,
to be able to take so many things for granted,
especially to be able to take other human beings for granted.
And that is sadly,
uh,
the,
the kind of the,
the most fundamental truth,
um,
about Edison Hunter.
So it is about social type.
There's no question about it.
Um,
but this,
the paradox,
um,
that,
that he,
that he becomes almost kind of extreme to house keys of the very,
very recognizable social profile.
Um,
just to show what a range,
um,
Fitzgerald has.
Um,
and the way that he can start at almost exactly the same
starting point,
um,
but end up in a different place.
Um,
I thought that maybe we should,
uh,
look at Babylon revisited.
Um,
it's also about a rich man,
um,
someone who has never eaten in a cheap restaurant in Paris.
Um,
I mean,
I think that that really is the reason why very high rate,
you know,
it's not like we go to Paris every day,
um,
but,
uh,
not,
never even in a cheap restaurant in Paris.
So that is the,
that is the fresh hold,
uh,
for,
um,
for Charlie.
Um,
and it would be all too easy,
uh,
to,
suggest.
Okay,
here's another rich boy and this kind of conformity to tight.
Um,
well there's also interesting about Charlotte is that he has in common with
[inaudible] in the fact that they both are hot trinkets razor four or five to 10
years is really nothing.
It's just the norm.
Just the beginning really.
Um,
so the hot drinking,
they're taking things for granted.
Um,
the lack of variety and experience,
um,
that all those things they have in common because they are so rich.
Um,
all those things they have in common.
But what is interesting about Charlie is that in fact his life has very,
very different trajectory from that have answers and it's actually a happy
ending.
So let's see what happens at the very end of,
um,
of,
of Charlie's story.
Babylon revisited.
He went back to his table,
his whiskey glass was irritated,
but he shook his head.
When Alex looked at it.
Questioningly there wasn't much he could do now except sen on area.
Somethings he was send her a lot of things tomorrow.
No.
Numora he said to another way though what,
which I owe you.
He would come back Sunday.
They couldn't make him pay forever.
He wanted his child and nothing was much good.
Now besides that fact,
he wasn't young anymore with a lot of them,
those thoughts and dreams to have by himself.
He was absolutely sure Helen when has wanted him to be sold off.
So right here we can see a lot of very,
very important differences between Charlie and Anson.
The first thing we notice is that this is someone who stopped drinking.
Right?
You know,
who has,
I mean that is sort of an obvious fact that someone was embarrassing the point
now.
But there it is,
it is very important for Fitzgerald who had a problem with alcohol,
alcoholism,
um,
that that should be the case.
That this person has enough self control to say no when it would have been so
easy to say yes.
Um,
but more than that,
that that is actually just the manifestation of something being different is
that he has one very important person in his life.
And what is interesting is that this is actually not a romantic interest,
right?
So this is what is missing in ends in Hunter's life as a child.
Um,
and we know that Fitzgerald himself had said many things about his daughter,
Scottie,
um,
that it broke his heart to think that when Scotty grew up the,
his novels with no longer be input,
right?
You said that about the great Gatsby.
So we do know that that fist general had a personal knowledge of what it means
to have a child and to think about the future in terms of the future of that
child and wanting to share the future with that child.
I think that that actually is what gives them future.
So we actually very close to the world,
Hemingway,
uh,
have to have and have not,
which is the future appearing by virtue of the mediation of someone else.
In this case,
it is not Harry's wife Marie,
who enables that future and an affirmative future to take shape.
It is not his wife,
but his daughter on the area.
Um,
so his future is defined in terms of today I'm going to give her some things
tomorrow I'm going to give her a lot more things.
It's the pleasure of being able to give his daughter a lot of presence.
That is what makes him work hard.
You know,
he's very,
very good at his job,
was making tons of money,
is very,
very uh,
trusted by his employers.
Um,
is all that is giving him a certain kind of relation to time.
So in that way,
I think that both Hemingway and father,
uh,
sort of implicitly present in a story is how do we get to have to start being a
social type and how do we get to have a personal and a highly interestingly
populated relation to the future.
The future is not any good unless it is populated by something.
And in this case,
child's future is very much populated by his daughter.
And that is because of the way it is popular later that he wants to get to that
future.
Right.
You know,
it's not a hobby leader.
You might not even want to go there and you might want just to stay where you
are,
but it was populated in such an interesting way.
He does want to go there and he wants to go there with her.
So this is the,
the,
the main difference,
um,
between Charlie and ensign.
And what is also interesting is that he enables,
it enables him to think about his wife,
Helen,
um,
that who died,
who's,
uh,
in very difficult circumstances when they were reconciled,
but not really,
it was not a good marriage.
Um,
it was through the mediation of his daughter.
There's able to think about his wife,
whom he had probably brand in some sense,
but she's there now.
There's no way for him to write that role.
So the only way he can write that wrong that otherwise would have been permanent
is once again through the mediation of his daughter.
So immediated personal identity and then mediated relation to the future.
Um,
and,
um,
so these other two stories,
but I should say,
um,
that,
they have a lot in common in the sense that in terms of narrows the structure of
the stories,
um,
because even though it's a happy ending for Charlie,
because the future is going to happen so slowly is it's a kind of very slow
happening,
slow pace in from mellow emergence of tomorrow,
right?
He's going to give money to his sister in law.
That's the implication.
That's how he would get his daughter back who's gonna pay for everything to get
it started back.
He's going to give his dollar loss and loss of presence.
So are those going to happen one day after another?
There's not going to be a kind of dramatic change in his life is strictly
incremental,
but because it is steadily in for Amanda,
we know that his distant future without say,
be significantly different from the today.
Um,
but neither of those stories where I say,
um,
you know,
it's really dramatic.
So let's turn now to the other side of the narrative spectrum.
Two stories are very,
very dramatic.
Um,
and one advertising the drama in the title diamond as big as the risk.
so we don't,
this is probably the most famous short story by Fitzgerald and I will encourage
you to say to discuss in session whether another that is indeed your favorite
story is certainly very,
very unforgettable.
So there's off the charts deviation from an extremely tight rich boy,
um,
and drama and large scale.
I was thinking the catastrophe at and the story tomorrow is going to be
different from today,
but let's just look at the way Fitzgerald proceeds to talk about is very,
very extravagant.
Well,
um,
that really truly is nothing like the world as we know it.
Sing.
My school is half an hour from Boston in the rose peers.
My other car,
the actual distance whenever we'd be known for no one except John t Unger had
ever arrived there,
safe in the rose peers and probably no one will ever again,
this is all on the same page as never having eaten in a cheap restaurant in
Paris.
Um,
but uh,
so that is the norm.
The norm is of it's very,
very,
extremely,
this is a school is the most expensive boarding school in the world,
um,
and is unheard of for anyone to go there and not owning a rose,
rose,
rose peers.
Um,
so that is the baseline of very,
very high threshold.
But even on that very high threshold,
Percy is still a deviation.
So it's definitely a deviation from an extreme type.
And one measure of that deviation is the kind of car opened by the family.
Um,
so when they got to Montana,
uh,
John,
sees that this,
this kind of luminous,
this that's coming at him,
um,
and has no idea what that is.
Then as they came closer,
John saw that it was the tail like men's automobile,
larger and more magnificent than anything he'd ever seen.
His body was a gleaming matto Richard and they go lighter than silver and they
help.
So the wheels was studded with iridescent and geometric figures of green and
yellow.
John did not dare to guess where they were.
Glass of jewel.
Um,
I just want to stop for a moment and um,
talk about paper.
Possible pay per topic,
um,
that would be perfect for the paper.
That is 10 pages,
uh,
which is the automobile and fish Gero and often,
right.
We know that,
um,
Jason can smell stand the smell of gasoline,
that he has terrible headaches because of his relation to the gasoline.
Um,
so it was very interesting take on cars on flockler spot and we know that uh,
Fitzgerald,
uh,
selling dramatizes,
and turns the Gaspe is Rose Rose into a kind of surreal car,
um,
kind of mythic car.
And here he's coming back to that.
So usually the car is a very,
very concrete point of entry.
We can actually talk about very large structures,
um,
in both Faulkner and Fitzgerald.
To what extent is the Rolls Royce and animal them of,
um,
of,
of Gatsby.
We also know that they saw another car with,
um,
three black,
black man in a black woman in a car and driven by what the chauffeur.
That's part of the story as well.
You know,
that's the configuration.
So we can use the very concrete object of very well defined object the car and
talk about this symbolic constellation revolving around that car.
In the case,
uh,
of,
of Fitzgerald definitely it would be a kind of social landscape.
Um,
the jazz age,
um,
and in the case of flogging actually has to go back to the relation between the
19th century in the 20th century,
right?
So the horse as relic of the 19th century being player,
the automobile.
So using the card you can write a great paper that would be very specific and
that would move from a small focus to a large argument.
Um,
so I would encourage you in writing your papers to think of similar structures,
stuff from something extremely well defined and then goes on to something
larger.
But in any case,
um,
as we can see,
Ashley,
um,
Race Fisher was fascinated by the relation between because of race.
So,
uh,
the string bother the,
the car is memorable in here,
uh,
in this story,
diamond as big as the risks.
Um,
and it turns out that it also has a very important racial dimension.
we know that,
um,
the,
that the,
the black arrows are still slaves in this story.
Right?
Um,
and they were originally broad,
uh,
broad from the south and they had always been in the recession of the family.
So this is what happens,
um,
to this,
uh,
black slaves.
All these negros are descendants of the ones my father brought north with him.
They are about 250 now.
You know,
there's that they've lived so long,
a pause from the world that their original dialect has become an almost in this
thing.
Fishbowl told us,
and he goes on to say that he actually trains a few of them just to speak
English so that they could communicate with the rest of the world,
but all the rest,
the 250 of them actually speak Patois or a dialogue that has no relation or is
so far removed from English that it would not be a recognizable language to
English speakers.
Um,
so that in itself is almost like a little vocal,
um,
allegory for the relation of this particular,
family and,
um,
the Washington family.
Um,
and,
um,
the unsustainable relation,
between today and tomorrow you can keep on in the middle of the United States
speaking a language that is supposedly English but really has no relation to the
English spoken by everyone else is just not a viable way of living in the United
States.
Um,
thinking that you were still speaking English when you was,
isn't recognized as English by anyone else.
It's another sustainable then we're sticking relation and it's also an
unsustainable relation to train this one close well that wants to remain close
and the rest of the United States that is dynamically expanding and also trying
to integrate or locales into a kind of national grip.
So this is what happens.
Um,
when we know this,
that this one important aspect of the Washington family that is clearly not
going to last forever and it,
this pant wise is not going to ask wherever it's going to die out is going to be
contaminated by the living English language.
Um,
that this is going to die out.
What ours is going to die out about.
The,
what else is going to die out by this particular set up,
this close?
Well that fantasizes about being closed forever and we see very soon that in fat
the n is going to come faster than we think.
It only takes a few pages really for the end to arrive.
Um,
and is drama on a very,
very,
very large scale indeed simultaneously and within,
in men's concussion,
the should told newly through itself into the air bursting into flaming
fragments at rose and then tumbling back upon itself and is smoking pile.
But later projecting half into the water of the lake,
there was no fire or smoke.
There was drifted off in England with the sunshine and for a few minutes longer
the powdering dust of marvel drifted from the great futile is pile that had once
been houser jewels.
There was no more sound in the three people will loan in the valley.
So the ending in many ways is not surprising.
Um,
is a very interesting combination.
on the one hand is highly dramatic.
On the other hand,
there's the element of predictability to that drama.
We always know without some catastrophe is going to happen.
And the story,
um,
and I think that oil is actually very comfortable with that kind of a
combination hydroma with almost no suspense.
Um,
we know almost from the very beginning that probably something very,
very bad.
It's going to happen.
And as story,
um,
so it's,
uh,
the,
and we also know just from a very desolate landscape at the end of the story,
um,
that the tomorrow is going to be totally different,
uh,
from the today within the story.
Um,
so,
um,
I have to confess that I liked the story a lot,
but I actually like drama on a smaller scale.
So when these bath,
my hair bobbed her hair is actually my favorite story among the Fitzgerald,
the stories.
Um,
and I hope that you see why it's about reversion to the original and type and an
unknown future.
So,
um,
Fitzgerald,
I think really like the story as well.
So that is the story that is feature in the cover,
uh,
on the cover of the collection of short stories.
Um,
flappers and philosophers.
And,
um,
if you guys,
if the word flappers,
um,
if that doesn't ring a bell right away,
this is an image of the very famous flappers of the 19th 20th people who've
bought the hair and wear short skirts,
show the legs and so on.
Um,
so the flappers,
um,
but the,
so you guys know that the story is really about someone who's becoming a flap
beneath is going to do,
I mean has,
if I cut off all her beautiful hair,
you know,
tons and tons of hair,
it's just cut it off,
has it cut off.
Um,
but I tried to tell her that's exactly the wrong hair do for herself.
She's very,
very ugly after that.
Um,
and who bows stop Bose lose all interest in her.
and um,
she was one person to thank and cousin.
So this is what happens to the person that she has to think when he's definitely
amputated the other break.
Her cousin Margaret,
um,
is sleeping.
And this is what happens to moderate when she's asleep,
when he's definitely amputated.
The other Embry pause for an instant.
And then with Lee and silently back to him.
And after minutes Brisbois,
she discovered that her left hand still held and two blond braids.
She left unexpectedly had to show them of hard to kill from the in and name and
absolute peel.
She was passing Warren's house now and on the empowers,
she sat down her baggage and swinging the brace,
like pieces of rope flung them at a wooden porch when he landed with a slight,
but she laughed again.
No longer streaming yourself,
Huh?
She giggled wildly scalp the selfish thing.
So I mean,
you know,
it really is in one sense is no big deal here.
Will grow out,
his hair will grow out madres hair with also grow out.
So cutting off somebodies brazed is not like the end of the world as it is in
the diamond.
As big as the risk,
but still,
you know,
it's interesting kind of drama.
And what makes the dramas especially interesting is the fact that monetary,
that the bunny is actually uses the word scalp,
which is a work not used in the 20 in the 20th century.
Um,
it goes all the way back to the 19th century,
18th century,
uh,
has to do with native and native American practice.
So in order to understand this odd use of language,
um,
I think that we need to,
with the help of another sociologists and anthropologists very well known,
one of the most important thing that was really,
um,
in the 19th century and late 19th century into the 20th century,
many authors or certain new host and Ashley's study were Franz Boas at Columbia.
Um,
so Franz Boas,
um,
had,
of
interesting argument about human types as well.
And it turns out that he is turning the notion of type on his hat and this is
what he says in 1911 when for instance,
it is claim the certain types of Europeans,
so Bella mantle endowment than other types of Europeans.
The assumption is that these types are stable and cannot undergo far reaching
changes when please in a new social or geographical environment.
And investigation of this problem shows that the assumption of an absolute
stability of human types is not plausible.
Okay.
So Franz Boas as the,
okay.
It looks like on the face of it looks like there are different types of domains
and yes,
when we look at the human faces,
um,
you know,
they really are different human types,
pretty undeniable,
but he doesn't think that there's any permanent to those types of things.
In fact,
even though you might be born into one time,
uh,
when you're put in a different social or geographical environment,
um,
you Ashley that type Attic as radically modified.
So it's very much in arguing about the importance of environmental input and the
way you can change your initial genetic makeup and to prove his point.
Franz Boas Ashley is in,
became a performance artist.
Um,
so this is Franz boas dressed up as an inward at otherwise known as basketball,
uh,
to uh,
show that yes,
a Caucasian man can look just like an into it.
And here he is dressed up,
not dressed up at all.
Um,
as a native American and proving that yes,
the Caucasian can look like a native American.
There is no permanent social type,
no permanent biological or genetic type.
Those,
the constant shifting of boundaries among those types as well as the possibility
of put the person at one time taking on the identity of another type.
So I think that that is the context for understanding.
Uh,
the very odd use of the work would scalp on a pilot open ears and it turns out
the first Gero cause actually prepares us for that development much earlier in
the story when they were actually just talking about [inaudible] as being
totally Dell and having nothing interesting to say and just sitting around all
day and doing nothing and being totally boring.
Um,
when they were talking about her in that context,
um,
Marjorie actually has this interesting theory that maybe she's so dow and boring
and submissive because just just like one of the native American women,
I think it is that crazy Indian love in beliefs,
continual knowledge.
Right.
So when she was saying that,
making that observation,
that one is that that Bernice is really like the native American women.
But it turns out that yes,
she has them in the blood,
but what's your,
with sandals if not the Indian woman by the Indian warrior.
And that is really,
it was coming up in that dramatic a amputation of my xrays,
um,
uh,
braids.
So the language of course is mock heroic.
Um,
it is,
uh,
using the language of high drama,
talk about something that really,
um,
is a very small incident.
But nonetheless,
it's very interesting story and it's the only story where we don't know what the
future is going to be.
Right.
You know,
that night that Bernice has done this thing,
there's al character,
we just don't know what the future will hold for her,
whether she would keep on,
on this path that this is just the beginning of a new career and a new personal
identity for her.
Whether she would revert Ashley back to a very quiet,
pretty submissive type that she was before.
So this is the only story I think where we truly don't know if I'm,
the tomorrow is going to resemble today.
And I think that it has to do partly with that very unexpected reversion to an
original type.
Um,
so the least we can say is that Fitzgerald is someone who really plays on all
the possible permutations of soldiers,
have,
can't think of anybody more inventive,
um,
having war to bring,
you know,
to that kind of permutation.
Uh,
so we're done with this girl and a on Thursday we'll move on to father and as I
lay dying.